did you know that you had the white
people's butts when you took the job no
how did you find out
they go you got to clean it up
and one one one it's horrible one woman
this is
anyway she was really sick you know and
she couldn't control herself so she went
to the bathroom in her bed and it was
like it was like two
it was horrible it was like two giant
balls of chili
so you had to get a towel
a big towel and scoop it up and put it
in the trashcan
yeah i scooped it up and it and i put in
the trash can and it was like sliding
out of the trash can and i was started
to throw up why didn't you put it in the
oh my god so i ran out of the room and
i'm gagging you know threw up and there
was a nurse cheryl big she's about huge
she's like six two
you know 200 300 pounds i go cheryl i
i
i can't do it i can't go back in i'm
going to throw up
just john
it's your job just take a deep breath
and go back in
wow those are good words and i was like
oh
why would you clean the [ __ ] like two
bowls of chili of [ __ ] and why would you
dump it in the waste paper basket it was
so much
it was a giant amount
but isn't it too much
it was i was 21. i'll never forget it i
can't get out of my
head so there was so much
you couldn't just like wipe it it was
like a bowl of
chili
and the one it was
i felt bad for her but it was just
oh my god so then and then they go is it
is it better being doing the critic of
voiceover than being an orderly
no no no it's much better wiping
people's butts